- Do you have an evening routine?
- Yeah.
Sometimes.
Not all the time.
- Hey guys, just got home from
a hectic day in the hospital.
But this week I love to
share with you my evening
or night routine.
Whatever it is you wanna call it.
Everything I do from the
moment that I get home
all the way to the moment
at which I go to bed.
I'd love to rest, but I can't just yet
because it's gym time.
Because it's gym time.
You're gonna hear a lot
of people talk about how
it's not smart to exercise at night
because it messes with your sleep,
it ruins the amount of
REM sleep that you get.
And I don't think that's
true for everybody.
I hear a lot of patients
that do exercise at night.
It actually helps them fall asleep faster
and get better quality sleep.
Try it.
Try working out in the morning.
Try working out at night
and see what works for you.
(soft music)
Just got back from the gym.
The first thing I like
to do right after the gym
is to get my dinner ready.
why after the gym?
It creates an insulin
spike within your body
which drives the nutrients
into your muscles
that are now nutrient depleted.
I have my veggies.
I have some carbs.
And you wanna eat at
least two to three hours
before going to sleep because
if you eat immediately
before going to sleep,
your body starts creating
a lot of gastric acid within your stomach
and that gastric acid end
up spilling right back out
into your esophagus when
you lay down in bed.
Do you eat before going to sleep?
- Yes.
A lot.
And I know I shouldn't (chuckles).
- Pretty much, yes.
- Within an hour probably.
- I must say I have
cheated some Chinese food
before sleeping at night.
Doctor would probably say give
me an hour to digest the food
before I head into sleep.
(soft music)
- Excuse me.
Water is really important for you here,
not only have you been
sweating during all that work
you've out into the gym.
But also water speeds up your metabolism.
Most people don't know that.
But countless studies have proven
that when you're well hydrated,
your metabolism works that much better.
One of the last things I
do before I go to sleep
for my evening routine
is take my little husky
out for a walk.
Right, Roxy?
Roxy.
Roxy's obviously gotta
get her evening walk in.
She's gotta use the bathroom.
Ooh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Dodging branches.
I don't like doing work at night.
I'd much rather wake up
in the morning earlier
than go to sleep at night later.
Plus, at night I get
all these distractions,
people texting me, I'm
looking at social media
but in the morning, all of that is quiet.
No one is on social media.
No one is messaging me
at five AM, trust me.
There is something I don't
mind taking out the time to do
and that's planning my following day.
It certainly eases my
anxiety to put all the things
down on paper that I have
to accomplish the next day.
It allows me to stay on track.
It allows me to stay focused
and most importantly,
it takes away that burden
of having to go to sleep
worrying that you need to wake up
and remember certain facts.
Just put it down on paper
and forget about it.
It really does allow you to
stay on track the following day
and be better suited to execute
the same night time routine.
And when you do that, you're
brain stays in a pattern.
And remember, your brain loves patterns.
A lot of the top CEO's
talk about something
called decision fatigue.
What is decision fatigue?
- Like, getting tired on purpose.
- I have not heard of that term.
- What's that?
- Decision fatigue is when
your mind get so tired
of having to decide between
option A and option B
that it ultimately just makes any decision
without fully thinking out the process.
- Freaking idiot.
- At night, you wanna have
only dim lighting around.
And the reason for that is
when you have bright lights
or you have white lights, blue lights,
it really does affect your melatonin,
which hurts how fast
you're able to fall asleep
and really the quality
of your sleep altogether.
Also, don't do the
planning process in bed.
The only things you should be doing in bed
is sleeping or having sex.
- Do you smoke after sex?
- I don't know baby, I never looked.
(laughing)
- Do you brush your teeth at night?
- I floss.
- Just floss?
- Yes.
- Every night?
Sure.
- Yeah, three times a day for sure.
- I do, I brush my teeth.
I brush my teeth like
two to three times a day.
- Yes, my mom's a dentist.
- Absolutely.
- Twice a day.
- We're all brushing our teeth at night.
I hope.
From cardiovascular protection,
keeping your heart healthy,
decreases in gingivitis,
cavities, all these problems
that you do not want,
just brush your teeth
twice a day for at least two minutes.
That's the official recommendation.
Time to floss.
Yes, play with this little white string
and guide it across your
teeth and clean your gums.
Yes, it prevents tooth decay.
Yes, it prevents gum disease.
But also, it prevents
inflammation in your entire body.
We've shown that those
who have heart attacks
generally have poor dental health as well.
So, take care of your teeth.
Floss often and floss daily.
It's really crucial to your health.
Do you floss?
- Definitely (chuckles)
- Are you lying?
- Totally.
(laughing)
- No, that's my one downfall
of being a dentist's child.
- Do you know your mom might see this?
- Yeah and she'll be disappointed.
- Do you floss?
- Yes.
- Are you lying?
- No no no no (laughing).
- I floss but
- Are you lying?
- I, I'm not lying but
- I'm lying a little bit.
- Do you floss?
- No.
- Okay, he's honest.
Next, we're gonna be
talking about how I maintain
my body's largest organ.
- Oh hell no.
- Skin.
A lot of people have very
complicated skin regimens
where they're putting on
one lotion after another
with a toner, this, that
in a specific order.
It's really too much.
I like to keep things simple as I do
in every other aspect of my life.
I likes to use a really
good quality face wash
with some exfoliant in
it, rub it on my face,
take some of the dry skin off
and then I like to follow
it up with some moisturizer
because your skin does get dry,
especially at night when we
have the air conditioners,
the heaters running.
I will dedicate a video to
just taking care of your skin
in the near future.
Be on the lookout.
My night's finally coming to a conclusion.
I planned the rest of my day tomorrow.
I got all my tasks out of the way.
Now it's time for me to just unwind,
catch up on my latest Netflix shows.
Today I'm gonna give El Chapo a chance.
I heard some great things about the show
from buddies of mine.
In this video, I'm not gonna cover sleep
because I think sleep is
such an important topic
that it deserves its own video.
I know some of you have parts
of your nighttime routine
that are totally unique.
I'd love to hear about them.
Leave it down below in the comments.
I'll respond.
I'll chime in with some medical advice.
If you have yet, definitely hit subscribe.
And most importantly, have a great night.
(cheering)
After dinner is generally the time I take
to sit down and answer all of
your comments on social media.
You guys put a lot of effort
into writing your questions
and comments on my social
media, so, I wanna take
an equal amount of effort to respond
instead of just giving you
a like or a thanks reply.
It's incredibly important that you switch
all of your devices to night shift mode.
It's a specific mode
that allows those devices
to decrease the amount of blue light
that they expose you to.
Studies have shown that
the more blue light
or short wavelength light
that you're exposed to,
the worse your quality of sleep is
because you're getting less REM sleep
and also the harder it is
for you to fall asleep.
So, switch all your
devices to night shift mode
and save yourself that headache.
Do you have an evening routine?
- Kind of, yeah.
Do I have to, do I have
to tell you what it is?
- If you're (mumbling)
brrrrrr, ow-a!
- I usually take a shower
and then I wash my face off.
- When you say wash your face
off, that sound dangerous.
What do you mean?
Do you have an evening routine
before you go to sleep?
And if so, what do you do?
- I eat,
(laughing)
smoke,
- okay
- And maybe (beep).
- How do you reduce anxiety
before you go to sleep?
- I cycle for like 50 miles.
You will really reduce
your anxiety doing that.
Of that you can be sure.